ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
the 45th and final
President of the United States.
Somber.
So somber.
You see that?
No applause.
My choice-- because this
has been a tough week.
And, folks, I understand tone.
We suffered such great loss
at the hands of a man
who we were saddened to learn
is not a Muslim.
(laughter)
I wanted so badly
for him to be a Muslim.
Even ISIS wanted him
to be a Muslim.
Which is proof that sometimes
it takes a tragedy
to unite us.
Wow! Look at that tone!
This is a chance
for all Americans
to set aside our differences,
no matter which side
of the aisle you're on.
From the obstructionist,
freedom-stealing Democrats
to the un-American
witch-hunting Democrats,
we can't politicize
our politics!
Somber.
(laughter)
It's in times like these
we must search for answers.
That's why tonight's theme
is "Why?"
I know, as Americans,
we're all asking ourselves
the same question:
Why did this have to happen...
during my presidency?!
So many bad things.
Three hurricanes,
all these investigations
into my stupid campaign,
getting trash-talked
by that Puerto Rican lady mayor!
I mean, haven't
I been through enough!
Tone.
Somber.
Nobody understands
how hard it is for me.
Somber Trump.
To walk out here tonight
to no applause at all.
These people want to clap.
You can't see them,
but they're dying to clap.
-(laughter)
-Isn't that right?
But I-- no.
But I told them not to.
And for that,
I should be applauded.
Okay, now! Do it!
-(cheering, applause)
-Look at that.
We're already healing.
I'm the president!
Can you believe this?
Let's roll!